à seulement 35 ans dina gilbert et la
nouvelle chef d'orchestre des grands
ballets canadiens
elle dirige actuellement casse noisette
honnêtement je me pince pense à chaque
jour je trouve vraiment j'ai une grande
chance bien élevé dans une famille de
mélomanes
elle n'aurait jamais imaginé devenir un
jour maestro pour moi un chef
d'orchestre
bien entendu c'était un grand musicien
d'un certain âge et pour moi c'est comme
le métier d'astronaute je savais que ça
existait mais l'opportunité que j'aurai
en rencontrer un jour dans ma vie était
très mince ce canton ville de saint
georges de beauce
grâce à son talent son travail assidu et
son oreille exceptionnel elle connaît
une ascension fulgurante
rapidement après ses études elle devient
chef assistante de quelques nagano ça
reste un menteur exceptionnel ça a été
extrêmement inspirant pour moi de
travailler avec lui pendant trois ans et
ça ça m'aurait malgras m'inspire et
c'est pour c'est certainement grâce à
lui en fait que j'ai autant de désir de
pouvoir faire ma part ma façon ma
différence auprès des orchestres et les
musiciens de l'osl garde un excellent
souvenir de son passage
des fois on voit des chefs qui qui
dirige juste avec le bas dessus est ce
qu'on appelle le trafic trop c'est trop
mais elles tendent des détails avec les
deux mains à l'un des répertoires variés
faut pas juste un répertoire classique
fait pas offert le hip hop mais sur 5
sur 10 à ne pas se limiter juste un
créneau
elle n'était effectivement pas métis et
les styles comme lorsqu'elle a donné aux
concerts alliant orchestre symphonique
et musiques de jeux vidéo
ou encore lorsqu'elle a accompagné des
rapports avec l'orchestré philharmonique
de radio france
on enrichit notre démarche n'a été
repris qu'à chaque fois qu'on vende
l'heure de notre cadre respectifs très
sollicité elle est à la tête de deux
autres orchestres au pays est
régulièrement invité à se produire un
peu partout sur la planète
si la machine comme cela où elle donne
aussi des conférences pour inspirer les
leaders de demain
disciplinés et précise lorsqu'elle mène
à la baguette
elle fait preuve de souplesse lorsque
vient le temps de parler d'avenir
je me laisse porter par ce que jusqu'à
présent ça a été seulement des belles
surprises
honnêtement donc j'ai pas un objectif
précis autre que le fait que j'adore la
musique est une grande passion que je
veux la faire découvrir au plus grand
nombre une pote doutes et leurs dons
pour communiquer sa passion
ici les biens lexandre charti radio
canada montréal
[Musique]